l'impression se confirme aux États-Unis
que le président Nixon n'a pas convaincu
l'opinion en évoquant l'affaire du
Watergate l'autre nuit à la télévision
et il y a sans doute plus grave un
véritable malaise s'est instauré chez
les élus républicains le parti de
Monsieur Nixon on en veut pour preuve le
fait qu'un sénateur républicain est fait
approuver par ses pères la désignation
d'un magistrat spécial et indépendant
pour mener l'enquête sur l'affaire du
Watergate un peu comme s'il se défiait
du nouveau ministre de la Justice
républicain bien sûr nommé par Monsieur
NX
Charles lambrkini a fait le tour des
réactions aux
États-Unis la presse a applaudi pourtant
de nombreux éditorialistes jugent que si
Nixon s'est finalement résolu à
l'inévitable il n'a pas encore fait tout
ce qui était nécessaire pour eux la
purge à la Maison Blanche n'est pas
terminée l'opinion ne semble pas moins
divise j'ai voté pour Nixon mais il a
trop attendu pour parler
nion ça risque d'être le
vietnamanten justement de ne pas pouvoir
me faire une
[Musique]
opinionfin
Watergate l'immeuble qui abrita
l'étatmajor électoral des démocrates
n'est pas loin de faire désormais figure
de monument historique en tout cas
l'immeuble est maintenant inscrit au
programme de tous les guides
touristiques de
Washington et à votre gauche voici
maintenant les fameux bâtiments de
Watergate
mais pour Nixon W paradoxalement une
raison d'espérer apparemment be jouur le
président en effet reconnu que la libre
action des institutions démocratiques
américaines avait seul empêché que le
scandale ne soit finalement étouff il a
même rendu hommage à ses vieux ennemis
les journalistes quoi qu'il en soit W
aura sans doute sonné le glas de cet
exercice solitaire du pouvoir si prisé
par Nixon